[Music]
foreign
[Music]
setting up security infrastructure is a
big step in protecting your apps and
data but set it and forget it won't fly
making sure everything is working as
expected identifying attacks and
breaches and fixing issues when it's not
working comes next welcome back to our
go deep with Google Cloud Armor Series
where we do demonstrations on
capabilities and features so you learn
what's available how to use it and how
you can leverage it in your environment
in our previous video we covered how to
configure rules and policies in Google
Cloud armor now we'll demonstrate how to
use monitoring and dashboards to ensure
your policies are working as intended or
to troubleshoot problems check out the
link in the description to see other
videos in our series playlists
visibility and Telemetry is key for any
comprehensive application protection
solution Cloud armor leverages the
Google Cloud Telemetry tools to deliver
this information in near real time
per request logs are captured and sent
to Cloud logging containing all
decisions that cloud armor makes with
regards to L7 requests as well as which
rules fired and why real-time Telemetry
for request volumes is available at
various levels of granularity through
Cloud monitoring including
pre-configured dashboards to help you
visualize and build alerting policies
custom dashboards using network security
policy metrics or log base metrics
security Command Center where correlated
security findings about unexpected
traffic spikes are sent to trigger
investigation and possible incident
response workflows and finally using
looker to do more powerful dashboarding
which first requires configuring a data
sync to export data from Google and
integrate it into any of your
visualization and dashboarding tools in
this video we'll cover how to use each
of these check out the the description
for the timing of each demo so you can
go to whichever one you want at any
point
up first let's look at using some
predefined dashboards in Cloud
monitoring to find Cloud monitoring in
the console you can go to the left hand
menu under operations or simply search
for it in the search bar
once in Cloud monitoring again in the
left hand menu of the console click on
dashboards
here you can see that we have all of our
dashboards in the dashboard list Tab and
we have a sample Library tab from the
sample Library you can find additional
dashboards to add to your list
under name we want to find and click on
network security policies you know it's
a predefined dashboard because the type
is Google Cloud platform when you access
the dashboard you see overall metrics on
the right
these include request volume metrics for
requests evaluated by a security policy
broken down by outcome
allowed denied previewed aloud and
previewed denied metrics can be observed
at varying levels of granularity on this
screen we see the metrics for the entire
project
getting into the breakdown by policy
name or clicking into the policies
allows us to see the metrics for a
specific policy
Beyond this we can create custom
dashboards
first we'll take a look at an example of
a custom dashboard and then we'll go
into adding additional metrics
I have here a cloud armor custom
dashboard that we created
you can see that the type is custom
we won't be covering how to create a
dashboard in Cloud monitoring in this
video but see the link in the
description for documentation on how to
do that
the dashboard we pre-made highlights
elements like traffic request volume
HTTP response codes total requests
traffic by country and more you can use
the add filter button to quickly filter
by variables like client country for
example select the country you want to
look at and we can get a high level view
of the traffic coming from that specific
Geo
this can be done with any other data
point that we have within the log line
now let's discuss metrics
let's first look at the per request logs
get comfortable with them and then we
can come back to how they can be
leveraged for monitoring
to demonstrate this let's hop into Cloud
logging and go to log Explorer Google
Cloud armor per request logs are logged
as part of logging for external https
TCP and SSL proxy load balancers they
include information like security policy
name match rule priority Associated
action and other related information
this is where you'd want to look first
to see if a particular policy set or
single rule is effectively doing what
you want it to do once these elements
are logged by Cloud armor they can be
turned into custom metrics and be added
into a dashboard in Cloud monitoring
using logging you can view every request
evaluated by a Google Cloud Armor
security policy and the outcome or
action taken
for example to view denied requests you
can use a query and log Explorer to
filter to only logs from cloud armor
where a request was denied
Cloud armor logs information about the
enforced security policy name priority
and configured action
most importantly it logs the outcome
which indicates the action taken by
Cloud armor allow deny redirect throttle
or rate base ban if a policy is
configured in preview mode Cloud armor
also logs the action it would have taken
if the rule was enforced you can set
different logging levels to help you
evaluate whether your security policies
and their rules are working as intended
we recommend that you enable verbose
logging when you first create a policy
make changes to a policy or troubleshoot
a policy this gives you detailed
information about why a pre-configured
WAFF rule was triggered by a particular
request which is extremely useful when
rule tuning
you can turn on verbose mode by running
the following command in Cloud show
in our previous video we had added a PHP
o wasp rule let's take a look at what
gets logged when verbose method is
enabled
as you can see here you get details
about the Matched field name type and
value that will be helpful for you for
debugging or rule tuning
now that we understand Cloud Armor's per
request logging let's get into log base
metrics by clicking on it in the left
hand pane
under user-defined metrics we can see
the metrics we have already created
let's click into the three dots menu and
click on edit metric
to see what goes into creating a log
base metric
under filter selection you can see the
logs we are using for creating the
custom metric
under labels we can see the specific log
Fields we're extracting to create log
base metrics
let's go back now
we'll click on discard as we didn't make
any changes
now we'll review how to add the log base
metric to a dashboard to do this click
into the three dots menu again and
select
view in metrics Explorer
once in metrics Explorer go into the
group by drop down menu and select the
labels that have been logged
click save chart
edit the name of the chart if you like
and select the dashboard to add this
metric into
this can be a new dashboard or a
previously created one like the example
I showed before
I'll choose to save it until my already
created Cloud armor dashboard
the confirmation pop-up comes up and if
I click view dashboard we can see that
the new metric has been added
so I can quickly zero in and see a
summary statement of what is going on
with my traffic in Cloud armor
now let's briefly touch on monitoring
with security Command Center or SEC we
won't be covering how to use sec in this
video but since it is a way to monitor
when using Cloud armor I'd be remiss to
not mention it
SCC is the security and risks database
for Google Cloud it includes a risk
dashboard and analytics system for
surfacing understanding and remediating
Google Cloud security and data risks
across an organization it's part of our
security operations workflows toolset
Google Cloud armor is integrated
automatically with SCC and exports three
findings to the SEC dashboard
a loud traffic Spike finding aptly named
notifies you of a spike and allowed
traffic on a per back-end service basis
a finding is generated when there is a
sudden increase in the allowed number of
requests per second compared to the
normal volume observed in recent history
increasing deny ratio finding notifies
you that there is an increase in the
ratio of traffic that Google Cloud armor
blocks because of a user-configured rule
in a security policy although the denial
is expected and does not affect the back
end service this finding helps alert you
to increases in unwanted and potentially
malicious traffic targeting your
applications it notifies you that the
app may be under attack the SEC
dashboard also contains findings from
cloud armors adaptive protection feature
adaptive protection uses machine
learning to help you protect your web
applications and services against layer
7 distributed denial of service service
DDOS attacks such as HTTP floods and
other high frequency layer 7 application
Level malicious activity links to a
video and documentation where you can
learn more about adaptive protection is
in the description the findings for
adaptive protection in SEC are located
in the Google Cloud armor card under the
application DDOS attacks category each
finding includes the details of the
backend service in question
the attack confidence
the signature associated with the attack
these are the details of what was
observed and what led to the detection
firing
and a link to the specific alert on the
Adaptive protection dashboard
SCC provides a holistic view of
information on various security
vulnerabilities for your organization
including some Cloud armor findings
alright let's keep going to our next
demonstration
next I'll demonstrate a more advanced
way to create custom reports using
looker but before we can do that we
first have to create a data sync and
then we'll export the desired log data
into bigquery
this process of creating a data sync and
exporting log data is really helpful to
master with it one can export Cloud
armor findings or any Google Cloud
products findings from cloud logging to
any third-party tool that you may want
to use like a Sim or sort to begin back
in Cloud logging under logs Explorer
click on more actions over here and
select create sync
name the sink and add a brief
description if desired
click next in the sync destination panel
select the sync service and destination
by using the select sync service menu if
you are routing to a service that is in
the same Cloud project you have one of
the following options
Cloud logging bucket select or create a
logging bucket
bigquery table
select or create the particular data set
to receive the routed logs you also have
the option to use partition tables
cloud storage bucket select or create
the particular cloud storage bucket to
receive the routed logs Pub sub topic
select or create the particular topic to
receive the routed logs
Splunk select the pub sub topic for your
Splunk service in this case we'll select
our Analytics tool bigquery and then
select the bigquery data set you can
either create a new one or select an
existing one for this demo we'll use an
existing data set
now we can create filters to dictate
what we want to have included in the
sink and what we want excluded out of it
click create sync
and we can then see back in logs router
that this Sync has been created and can
now be used in other parts of the system
now that we have our data sync set up
with our log data flowing into bigquery
let's use looker to more deeply analyze
our insights and create some custom
reports for this we'll leverage looker's
ability to directly connect to live data
in our bigquery database and demonstrate
some out-of-the-box capabilities looker
has to derive insights from that data
here is the looker interface and to
begin we have to click this button in
the upper right hand corner to go into
the looker Marketplace and deploy the
cloud armor module
looker calls these modules blocks there
is no additional cost for the cloud
armor block and it's very quick and easy
to apply into your looker environment
in the search bar here I'll type Cloud
armor and install the block
what this blog provides is some
pre-configured models with the ability
to explore and ask questions of the data
as well as some pre-created dashboards
to derive immediate insights from the
data as well
so if we hop back into looker and click
on the app one folder we can see that
the Google Cloud armor dashboard is now
live
open that up and see it's pre-filtered
to app one it's showing data for the
last seven days and if we scroll you can
see the different metrics and kpis that
are available depending on which of
these metrics are most useful to your
business you can take advantage of
Lookers alerting capabilities to alert
you when something reaches a certain
threshold by clicking the Bell icon on
this metric I can create an alert that
will notify me or whoever I specify when
requests are greater than seventy
thousand that can be accomplished by
email or by a messaging system like
slack at a selected frequency and time
and with specific permissions
click save alert and that is set now
let's explore how to create a custom
report
a custom report oftentimes begins with a
look or a dashboard that is already
created and there's a follow-up question
that we want to know the answer to so in
the cloud armor dashboard we can see
there is the top request remote IPS look
and we'll use this as our starting point
click into the three dots menu and click
explore from here now we are in the
Explorer mode and here we can tweak the
look to our liking
under filters I can change this to roll
up to the entire business versus just
app one and change the visualization to
a pie chart
in the edit menu I can further customize
this by turning the legend into labels
and other cool features
I can now save this under the gear icon
as a look
give it a name make sure the correct
folder is selected and now this report
is available for other users to see in
our app one folder under looks
if we want to make this look available
to other business units like app2 click
the three dots menu on the look copy and
select the desired business unit under
shared folders
then click ok
and now if I go into the app2 folder the
look is available there as well
from here I can save this look as a new
dashboard and we can use it as a
starting point to build a new custom
dashboard
click view dashboard
and my look is there
now if I want to continue adding content
I can go back into the explore mode
select Google Cloud armor that came with
the looker block we installed and create
my own custom look let's say we want to
see account of all actions that were
triggered using the side panel search
for enforged security policy configured
action then select count under measures
and hit run
looker then selects the best fit
visualization and I can edit this as I
choose maybe I want to see it as a bar
chart we can then go deeper and decide
to see this trending over time again in
the side panel I can type in time and
select event timestamp date it gets
added into my table View and then I can
pivot by the configured action
go back into visualization and make it a
filled line chart to see it trending
over time
and edit some of the customization
options to make it a bit prettier
by changing the line interpretation to
monotone
and stacking the lines
I can now save this the same way I did
before and add it to the custom app One
dashboard I created earlier
and if I go back to that dashboard
you can see that new content was added
Additionally the same way I copied the
look to another business unit before I
can copy this dashboard to another
business unit and provide users from
app3 the ability to see this dashboard
as well
now we can start to see some of the more
powerful visualization and data
analyzing capabilities that looker
offers to derive insights from your data
now if I want to deliver this dashboard
to end users directly I can once again
in the three dots menu click get link
copy it and share it that way
or schedule a delivery
by sending this as a PDF or other format
to specific stakeholders or an email
group
finally I'll touch on the fact that
Lookers interface allows for
localization and accessibility options
through the admin panel so for example
if you have users that speak different
languages you can change that in the
localization tab for the entire
interface
or on a per user basis in the edit user
section
select the language under the Locale
drop down
save
and you can see the left hand menu has
changed to French
so not only is looker more powerful for
analyzing and visualizing it also offers
the huge benefit of sharing insights
with other users easily
and that is our last demonstration for
the video as you can see with Cloud
armor there are many ways to keep an eye
on your data now you should be able to
use these options for monitoring and
dashboards to have up to the minute
notifications of attacks and major
shifts in the environment to assist with
SRE and secops as well as to extract
insights from cloud armor this will give
peace of mind that your configured rules
and policies are working correctly or
help address any issues if they're not
make sure to check out the links in the
description for helpful information and
if you found the demonstrations in this
video helpful make sure to subscribe so
you don't miss the upcoming videos in
the go deep with Google Cloud Armor
Series
thanks for watching
[Music]